hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the last portion of part four of his
discourse on method rene descartes
is going to examine this distinction
between the thoughts that we have while
we're awake and those that we have while
we're sleeping that is in dreams and
he's going to tell us why it is that in
general we can trust our waking thoughts
we can say that they actually do have
more truth in them than the thoughts
when we're dreaming and this is a big
achievement this is an important part of
the Cartesian master argument running
both through the discourse and through
the meditations on First Philosophy it's
actually explored a little bit more in
detail about how we how we work with
this criterion of clear and distinct
ideas in in the meditations but we're
gonna focus here just on what he has to
say in the last part of this section so
there are some previous concerns and
these come from the earlier part what is
it that we can doubt well we can doubt
the testimony of our senses we can doubt
whether we're getting mathematical or
logical argumentation correct maybe we
make mistakes and that and there's also
this this issue that Descartes brings up
you know I dream of all sorts of crazy
stuff so how do I know that I'm not
dreaming right now and that the things
that I think are happening you know for
example in my case filming right now
aren't just illusions that are produced
in my mind false ideas that don't
correspond to anything in reality so
this is the big previous concern he
knows that he does in fact have dreams
and in those dreams whatever they may
have been I mean Hart doesn't do a dream
journal or something
he thinks false things maybe he thinks
he's the you know King of France or
maybe he thinks that he's you know made
of taffy or who knows what else but
these things are false so how can we
trust
our ideas and we have this Cartesian
argument that you know runs throughout
the entire part four he begins in doubt
and it's hyperbolic doubt he's gonna try
to use it as a tool to doubt everything
possible he gets to the I exist I am a
thinking substance I can doubt
everything else but I can't doubt my own
existence because in order to do that I
have to think and there has to be
something that's doing the thinking and
then he argues to God's existence and
also the divine nature and throughout
this section he has been using this
criterion that whatever I conceive
clearly and distinctly must be true so I
I conceived clearly and distinctly that
I think therefore I exist I also you
know conceive that like my notion of God
couldn't have just come from nowhere or
from myself or something lesser than me
has to come from something greater than
me all of that is making use of this
criterion of clear and distinct
conception of ideas so it's not just
that the ideas themselves are clear and
distinct it's also that my conception of
them the way in which they are being
conceived or grasped is as clear and
distinct and this leads to what's often
called the Cartesian circle because
Descartes is going to argue based on
God's existence and God's nature of
being completely perfect which means
being completely good that God would not
create us in such a way as to sort of
naturally be deceived all the time he's
giving us kind of a lifeline in this
clear and distinct ideas whatever I can
see them clearly and distinctly I can
know to be true because God would not
have set things up in terms of my mind
or the world in such a way that whatever
I did conceived clearly and distinctly
would not be true so this is a problem
that doesn't get explored very much in
here but it's called the Cartesian
Circle we're not actually going to worry
about that here but I did want to note
it because this this notion of
your indistinct conception of ideas is
going to get used now as a way to try to
answer this issue of why are waking
thoughts true or not are the things that
in in our waking life right now we are
conceiving how can we actually have any
reliance on them and Descartes
approaches this in a very interesting
way he starts out by talking about
dreams and he notes that just because we
dream something doesn't mean that it's
automatically false so you know if I
dream that I'm made of chicken and you
know I'm actually drinking a milkshake
that's as big as the universe okay
that's clearly got to be false right and
we can make up all sorts of crazy stuff
like that but what if it's a geometric
proof what if it's some sort of logical
reasoning is that false simply because
it's being dreamed Descartes says once
the knowledge of God and of the soul has
made a certain of this rule about clear
and distinct ideas about participating
in in truth he says it's a simple matter
to determine that the things we imagined
in dreams should in no way make us doubt
the thought of the the truth of the
thoughts we have all awake even if one
should happen while sleeping to have
some very distinct idea here uses the
case of a geometers discovering some new
proof the fact that he was asleep would
not prevent it being true so that's the
criterion there so long as it's a very
clear a very distinct set of ideas that
are connected together in the proof and
you can replicate it and write it down
or you know talk yourself through it
once you awake it could be true you
don't have to doubt it just because you
dreamt it now simply because you dreamt
it doesn't mean that that's true so you
actually do need to sit down and go
through it and see whether the thing
that you feel to be true really is
true so there there's an important thing
there that the current sort of takes for
granted that you'll know what else does
he say what about things that we
perceive our senses like you know I've
had dreams sometimes where I get up and
I get dressed sort of like I am right
now and there are physical sensations of
you know the tightness of the the
clothing around you know parts of my
body and you know the colors when I look
down and stuff like that if I'm dreaming
that's all false right because I'm
laying there in my bed and unless I came
home you know very very late I'm not
laying in my bed wearing a tie and a
shirt or anything like that right I have
changed into something else
and decart presumably same same sort of
case should that make us doubt the
perceptions that we're having right now
Descartes says no so he goes on and he
says for the most common error of dreams
which consists in there representing
various things to us in the same way as
our external senses representing for
example a gold or yellowish and brown
sort of Thai soft right it does not
matter he says that it gives us occasion
to distrust the truth of these ideas why
not well it's an interesting argument
our senses could also mislead us without
our being asleep I could be wrong in
looking at the Thai he gives the example
of people who are jaundiced where
everything that they see looks kind of
yellowish so maybe this is actually a
great eye and I'm feeling sick my livers
failing and I've got jaundice and I'm
looking at him like that's a very
yellowish you know or I mean think about
this you know maybe I changed the
colours in the video now I don't have
that sort of technical expertise but I'm
sure there's plenty of people out there
who who do so in a way the dream thing
is a bit of a red herring at this point
our senses can deceive us anyway we
don't need to bring in the dream
argument anymore to worry about that so
what's the upshot of this he tells us we
should have some
trust in the truth of our waking
thoughts not all of them necessarily but
we don't have to be stuck in hyperbolic
doubt anymore
what's our way of doing that he says
that we we should be convinced on
evidence of reason not just in an
immediate way by the senses so when I
see a tie and I think it's a certain
color you know what would the evidence
of reason be for that maybe I should
actually go check the time maybe I can
talk with other people hey are you
seeing at this color now that's not
perfect that only gives us a certain
amount of probability but it would be
quite reasonable to trust in that
wouldn't it it would also be reasonable
you know when we put the stick into the
water and it looks bent to us for us to
say oh I know how this works
it's not really bent there's laws of
refraction of light going on here that's
an explanation by reason as opposed to
just relying on the senses right or
imagination can often play a major role
as we know from you know all sorts of
interesting studies you can get people
to see things that aren't actually there
and to not see things that are there or
to see them in very different ways so we
want to trust a reason rather than
imagination or sense he says I say our
reason not our imagination or our senses
and he gives the example the Sun we see
the Sun very clearly we should not on
that account judge that it's only as
large as we see it because if we you
know you're looking at the Sun it looks
like it's about that big it's awfully
bright but but you know so don't stare
at it too long but it looks like it's
pretty small but we know as he says that
it's actually quite large he says we can
imagine if we use the example of the
imagination the head of a lion grafted
onto the body of a goat but that doesn't
mean that we have to assume that because
we can imagine this that there is a
chimera of that kind of creature
anywhere in the world
he says reason does not dictate to us
that what we see or imagine in this way
is true so what does reason tell us
about thing
that could be true or it could be false
he says to begin with all of our ideas
have some sort of foundation in truth
even the things that are false or
imaginary purely fictional they have
some basis in something that actually is
true I can be deceived I can have all
sorts of illusions but they draw upon
you could say a stock of things that at
some time somewhere were actually true
now ferreting out what's true and what's
false that's a bit more difficult and
dick Hurtz not going to try to do that
right now the other thing that is he's
saying that's really important about
this issue of the truth of waking
thoughts is that our reasoning is more
clear and complete while we are awake so
we can trust this criterion of clear and
distinct conception of ideas more when
we are awake than when we are asleep now
does that mean that everything that we
do perceive while we're awake is
automatically true grasped clearly no
not not at all the case but there is a
difference between the waking state and
the dreaming state one that we often
lose sight of in the Dreaming state
which is that our ideas are not really
as clear and distinct or complete as we
would like to feel that they are so he
tells us that our processes of reasoning
are never so clear a complete when we're
asleep is when we're awake although our
imaginings and sleepers sometimes just
as vivid and distinct so reason tells us
that as our thoughts cannot all be true
because we're not wholly perfect what
truth
there is in them mustn´t must infallibly
be found in those we have while awake
rather than those which we have in our
dreams so where's Descartes ending with
us and we can't trust everything of our
ideas our thoughts as as true but we can
figure out that if there are going to be
true thoughts they're going to be waking
thoughts
and at least some of them are going to
be true for example I exist right that's
that's a true thought and he's going to
extend from this outward into the entire
realm of what comprise as we now call
them the sciences so there's a lot that
we can actually trust as true in our
waking thoughts and all of them have
some foundation no matter how false they
are some foundation in truth
you